ce qui joue au carcassonne ou encore
catane ce sont les jeux de société du
moment en plein essor l'attrait pour ces
jeux a été accélérée par les
confinements alors c'est vrai que les
jeux de société avait tendance à revenir
de plus en plus avec eux de plus en plus
de force les gens commencent à découvrir
qu'ils avaient des jeux de société
modernes mais je pense que le
confinement à créer une accélération en
fait de la chose avec ses 1500
références en jeu de tout type kevin
armand god le gérant ne veut pas
simplement être un lieu de vente
il compte organiser dès que possible des
soirées jeux on aura des soirées à thème
donc qu'ils vont être développées autour
ta foi de mécanique de jeu parfois
autour des nouveautés parfois aussi au
travers de jeux comme les jeux de rôle
dont féminisation jeux de rôle ou alors
faire de l'initiation à la peinture sur
figurines
l'occasion également pour les joueurs de
faire de nouvelles rencontres
c'est parfois de pouvoir rencontrer des
gens qui ont cette même passion ça peut
être sympathique on peut parfois
rencontrer des gens qui sont à deux rues
de chez nous mais qu'on ne connaissait
pas et là ce sera l'occasion justement
des rencontres et un cross fading avait
été lancée avant l'ouverture un succès
puisque le montant avait été largement
dépassé cet habitant de maurepas ils y
avaient participé
le crowdfunding a bien marché donc ça
veut dire que les gens avaient envie en
soi qu'une boutique de genre ouvre ici
les clients sont au rendez vous depuis
une semaine et demie ils attendaient
l'ouverture de cette nouvelle boutique
avec impatience je pense qu'une grosse
communauté de joueurs de tous types ans
ça peut être des familiaux ou plus
pointues et c'est vrai que à proximité
directe sur une communauté de l'agglo
comme saint-quentin plus la taille de la
communauté c'est un vraiment quoi deux
beaux jours sont donc à venir pour les
joueurs des environs qui pourront très
prochainement se réunir et jouer au tour
de table de la boutique